can't change overnight but we got to
start somewhere as here we
a ban Taylor this one isn't even
original what is
this because I guess it's supposed to be
subversive in that they took a Christmas
tree and they turned it into a BLM thing
but that's just a a k Quanza decoration
I mean all Quanza is is a black
identitarian a black liberation movement
guy who was a socialist creating a
socialist Festival to try to replace
Christmas I wish you'd get out of my
life and shut up the guy gave him self
the name Milana Kanga but his real name
is Ron Everett and he was a Cal State
Long Beach Professor who was later
arrested for torturing women and
imprisoning them and doing all sorts of
sick crazy things to
them dang and he was a nut and the
holiday is ridiculous and no one really
celebrates it at all